Ochs and the controversy over the
connection between antidepressants and
child suicides the Federal Drug
Administration announced last month a
new program to improve their assessment
of risks connected with drugs
next on book TV dr. John Abramson
delivers his own prescription for change
overdosed America the broken promise of
American medicine
the program is an hour I'm Marjorie
McCrum I'm a board-certified
anesthesiologist and I'm very delighted
to be here to introduce our speaker
tonight my own background has a little
to do with what John does but I am a
part-time anesthesiologist at the
Brattleboro retreat and I'm also a voice
teacher for 12 years that I was the
anesthesiologist at Brown Borough
Memorial Hospital and for six of that
years I was the chairman of the
department in 1999 I decided to go and
study music and get a master's in music
hence when I returned back here I was
very fortunate to get a job at the brown
borough retreat which allowed me to work
part time giving anesthesia and also
part time teaching singing in addition I
worked in a clinic for Integrative
health care and many of my fellow
practitioners are here where we try very
hard to bring the best of Western
medicine to alternative approaches and
create help that way so I'm very excited
about dr. Abramson's work and just to
give you some background on him he is a
Clinical Instructor at Harvard Medical
School and in the primary care division
and instructing medical students and
health staff for 20 years he was a
family medicine practitioner in the
Boston area and honed much of his skills
in doctor/patient relationships at that
practice he attended Dartmouth and brown
Medical School program and did his
internship in Chapel
he'll following that he entered the
National Health Services Corps which at
that time was part of the United States
Public Health Service and it was placed
in Appalachia at a rural clinic where he
got to see firsthand his first
experience as a family practitioner
following that he completed his
residency at Case Western Reserve and
then became a Robert Wood Johnson fellow
and studied research design statistics
and epidemiology health policy and
health care delivery systems to further
his study he then went to Brandeis
University the School of Social Policy
so he is uniquely positioned I think to
undertake this quest for truth and
expects sort of exposition or expose if
you will of the current status of
pharmaceutical companies and sort of the
the inbreeding between pharmaceutical
companies and the the political arena
most recently I think you'll find he was
right in the middle of the latest Merck
how would you describe that event with
the by oxen actually made an appearance
on ABC News last night so we are very
excited to have him here on he for me
validates and really substantiates much
of my own intuitive distrust of certain
aspects of the healthcare delivery
system and it's very gratifying to have
somebody who has both a clinical
experience as a family practitioner but
also has a tremendous background in
statistics which I would hazard a guess
that most of us regular physicians do
not get that critical expertise or
training so it is a very well position
that he is able to give us this
information so he's probably much more
adept at speaking than I am I'd much
rather be singing up here so I
we'll turn it over to dr. John Abramson
well thank you thanks everybody for
coming I I really share a lot of
Marjorie's interests in medicine as a
family doc for 20 years in the late 90s
I taught a course with dr. Herbert
Benson at Harvard Medical School
for the medical students about the title
of the course was healing and
spirituality but really my contribution
to the course was to talk about the
importance of relationships in the
doctor-patient relationships in the
effectiveness of the healthcare that we
deliver and this is a part of medicine
that just gets so ignored now as we've
moved towards technology and you'll see
as I get into the talk as we've moved
towards a commercial bias in what it is
we think of as good medicine so the good
medicine is now defined as using
products and and tests and procedures
that generate the the highest profits as
opposed to the best health and my
intention was to write a book about the
importance of those relationships I got
sidetracked and I got sidetracked but by
what I think is a real emergency in our
healthcare system it's really almost
unbelievable the way the American
healthcare system works and the way it
compares to other countries most people
aren't aware of this but out of 22
industrialized countries the United
States we spend twice as much per capita
on health care as the other countries
but of those 22 countries Americans will
live the shortest amount of time in good
health so we're spending twice as much
but we're having the shortest healthy
lifespans and the question is how can
that be happening that's what I want to
address tonight how can it look like a
good health care system and yet be
functioning so poorly that said I do
want to make it clear that much of what
goes on in our health care system does
work
is superlative all of medicine is not
being impugned here and the what I if I
could generalize what I would say is
American medicine is excellent when the
most lucrative solution to a problem is
the best solution so President Clinton
needed that heart surgery there were
arteries that were 90% obstructed he was
about to have a major heart attack the
United States is a good place to have
that heart surgery when he needs it but
in terms of preventing preventing him
from needing it the United States is not
such a good place to be so let me tell
you a little bit about how I made the
transition from being interested in
being a family doc staying up with my
journals and using the relationship that
I had with my patients to help them
towards health that really turned the
corner in August of 2000 as a
hard-working family doc I'm sure you
many of you here are docs and you've
seen your Docs you get pretty tired as
you go through the morning and I would
make a habit of kind of sequestering
myself in my office for 15 or 20 minutes
during lunch time and eat my lunch and
usually read a journal and one day in
August of 2000 I was reading the New
England Journal of Medicine and came
across an article called pravastatin and
the risk of stroke pravastatin is a
cholesterol a statin drug a
cholesterol-lowering drug the article
concluded that pravastatin proved a call
given to patients significantly reduced
the risk of stroke and that looked
interesting I had happen to have a
patient at the time true story I'll call
her mrs. rose that's not her name but
she was an 82 year old woman she had had
a devastating stroke and prior to her
devastating stroke she had made me
promise her one thing that I wouldn't
she would not end up in a nursing home
well she had a stroke and she ended up
in a nursing home she she couldn't speak
she was paralyzed on one side and it was
just dreadfully painful to go and see
her in the nursing home it and I knew
through her eyes that she was saying to
me you broke the promise so this article
that offered hope for me as a clinician
to reduce
my patients risk of having a stroke
caught my attention well turned out the
title of the article wasn't quite right
it wasn't really Provost at in the risk
of stroke was pravastatin and the risk
of stroke in people who've already had a
heart attack and it turned out that when
the numbers were adjusted meaning
corrected for imbalances in people in
the group that took the private call and
people in the control group when the
numbers were adjusted the findings were
no longer statistically significant but
then it caught my eye as I got into the
details and there's the kind of thing
from the fellowship that I had been
trained to do when I got into the
details of the study 83% of the people
in the study were men their average age
was 62 but it turns out that the average
age of a stroke patient is about 75 and
there are more women than men that was
important because for the people in this
study the people over 70 had 20% more
strokes when they took the private call
not fewer strokes for the women who took
the provoked all they had 26% more
strokes not fewer strokes for the
patients who weren't taking aspirin as
80 or 90% of patients don't people don't
they had 20% more strokes when they took
private call than that when they took
the control so what this study was was a
classic example it's a way that we can
load studies so they tend to come out in
the favor of the sponsor you do the
study on the wrong population a
different population than you're going
to generalize the results to and when I
looked at this study it was clear that
for the average stroke patient they
would have it would be a woman over 70
not taking aspirin and if the numbers
held they would have more strokes not
fewer strokes and I hadn't seen anything
like this in the New England Journal I
mean we all fit all the docs and nurse
practitioners and nurses were feeling
the commercial pressure coming on as the
90s progressed but I haven't seen
anything like this
that was so stark with commercial spin
in the New England Journal or any of the
most respected journals before so I I
put my analysis together and I went to
speak to a research expert at one of the
Boston universities I said look I
robert johnson fellow about 20 years ago
this has caught my eye and i'd like you
to take a look at this and just check my
reasoning if you would make sure that
i've got this story right so he looked
over and i made my argument just like
i've presented it to you and he said
yeah i think you got it right so so
we'll look why don't we write a paper
together and you're a researcher and i'm
a family doc we would have a lot of
credibility and we could help to
immunize physicians from getting sucked
in or misled by this kind of biased
information that's creeping into our
journals he said well I'd rather not I'd
do a little consulting for the drug
companies and I'd rather not get
involved and at that point I felt like I
in that moment felt like I have lost my
naivete because I believed that the role
of the university was to seek truth that
it was its responsibility was to oversee
the integrity of the knowledge that
practitioners in in in the instance of
medicine that practitioners based their
decisions on and I realized that it
wasn't just that the journals now were
becoming increasingly influenced by drug
company sponsored and commercially
sponsored articles but that the checks
and balances within the university were
being lost because if we don't have
experts within universities who can be
the critical voices if the critical
voices are now getting have financial
relationships with the commercial
sponsors then we have a problem and that
is the problem that I spotted and that's
really the point at which I shifted
gears and said no somebody's got to tell
this story nobody's telling this story
and I probably have the skills to tell
it and I'm going to invest some time in
telling it the next issue that came
along was celebrex and Vioxx
and this was I actually started to
understand the story about Vioxx on 9/11
2001 I remember I called a colleague
who's a Rheumatologist I had my head
buried in a computer at 11 o'clock in
the morning I called a colleague and
said do you understand what's going on
here these
numbers just are there's something
really wrong with this he said don't you
know we're at war and then I got my head
out of the computer and realized that
the tragedy of 9/11 had happened the
story with Vioxx is a very interesting
one with the private Collins stroke
issue with a pencil and a calculator and
some research skills not great research
skills but some research skills I and
other Doc's could figure out what the
truth of that article was but when you
get to celebrex and Vioxx the docs could
not figure out what the truth was and
this was more than spinning this was
really false and misleading information
so Vioxx has been in the news since the
recall of at the beginning at September
30th and let me tell you a little bit
about that problem because if we don't
understand what happened in Vioxx this
situation is going to play out over and
over again it's a serious situation and
we're not getting to the bottom of it
even with all of the discussion that
we're having now we're still not getting
to the bottom of it the story is this
Merck did a large study it involved
8,000 people with rheumatoid arthritis
half of them got Vioxx and half of them
were given naproxen which is an older
anti-inflammatory drug it costs if you
buy generically over-the-counter it
costs only a tenth or a fifteenth as
much as Vioxx the study was to determine
the safety and the effectiveness of
Vioxx compared to naproxen the study was
done in 1999 and completed in 2000 and
march of 2000 the results of that study
were published in the New England
Journal of Medicine in November of 2000
and that article this is very important
because that article concluded that
naproxen when given to patients with
rheumatoid arthritis causes
significantly fewer gastrointestinal
complications there was an issue with
heart attacks but when we looked at when
when the researchers looked at the
increased number of heart attacks they
found that if you took out the people
who didn't have a predisposition to
heart attack without any history of
cardiovascular problems
other folks who were not at increased
risk did not have more heart attacks
when they took Vioxx instead of naproxen
and the issue kind of faded the the
article concluded that there was not a
statistically significant increase in
the risk of heart attacks in people who
took Vioxx instead of naproxen who had
no predisposition and on the basis of
that article reasonable Doc's reading
one of our very most respected journals
concluded that Vioxx was a safer drug
for their patients no more effective for
arthritis symptoms but safer because it
caused fewer GI symptoms and we can't
medical knowledge really means what's
published in the medical journals we
can't ask our Doc's to go deeper than
reading carefully what's in the medical
journals the problem here is that that
study was completed in March the article
published in November Merck understood
that there was a serious problem in
March their lead research scientist
understood it said there was a serious
problem the internal documents were
revealed by the Wall Street you know the
Wall Street Journal article this Monday
and the problem is this that the bottom
line on that research data is that just
looking at the people who did not have a
predisposition of heart disease the
people who took Vioxx had twice the risk
of developing cardiovascular
complications as the people who took
naproxen cardiovascular complications
meaning heart attacks strokes and blood
clots and the FDA reviewer who looked at
this the cardiology reviewer said based
on the information that Merck has
submitted to us that information could
lead one to conclude that naproxen were
the preferred drug and naproxen and
preferred as underlined in the FDA
report so the FDA understood that this
was a problem the other very important
fact that was not included in the New
England Journal is that over all the
people who took Vioxx developed 21% more
serious complications
overall gee I heart disease everything
21% more serious complications than
naproxen so Vioxx is a significantly
more dangerous drug than naproxen it's
it's in black and white it's very clear
in the FDA report but neither of those
facts were included in the New England
Journal of Medicine article that's the
problem we can look at the FDA we can
say look the FDA reviewers did a heroic
job and I can if any of you are
interested I can tell you how to get to
these reports very quickly and two
minutes of clicking on the FDA website
you can get to the primary data
the FDA reviewers did a heroic job they
analyzed that data they drew the
courageous conclusions
they did not mince their words the
problem is it's as if they were working
in a soundproof room because those
conclusions didn't get out you needed to
be a Reese now a full-time researcher as
I was at that point you needed to be a
full-time researcher to get into this
data and to figure it out and I spent
more hundreds of hours understanding
this data and going back and forth
between the New England Journal article
and the and the primary data so this was
something different now this now we've
gone from spinning the evidence to
really misrepresenting the evidence and
it got even worse because in August of
2001 there was a review article
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine about celebrex and Vioxx the
review article said well there is a
problem with cardiovascular
complications but the numbers were small
there were fewer than 70 events and it
may just be due to the play of chance
now that caught my eye because play a
chance is odd language to use for
experts writing a review article when
anyone who's taken the first statistics
course it took me three for it to sink
in but anyone who's taken the first
statistics course understands that if
something statistically significant it
takes into account the number of events
that are there the smaller the number
events the bigger the difference has to
be to reach statistical significance
well this research article caught my
attention
then I noticed that the research article
was written by two Doc's who had
financial relationships with both of the
manufacturers of celebrex and Vioxx and
in fact that was in violation of the New
England Journal of Medicine editorial
policy at that time so that was curious
and then when I went back and looked at
the FDA data according to the FDA
statistical ant ant analysis analysts
report the play of chance the chance
that this finding was due to a random
event was one in 10,000 now for the New
England Journal of Medicine review
article to say the play of chance when
the chance is one in 10,000 is an
extraordinary I find an extraordinary
breach of the trust that Doc's have in
the medical journals we go through this
boot camp training at last many years
were up all night we get sometimes hmm
we present our patients in the morning
after having no sleep sometimes we get a
little bit beaten up if we don't know
all the facts and we don't know what's
in the latest journals and we get taught
that we damn well better know what's in
those journals and we better treat our
patients in accord with that but now I
was finding that I was doing that as a
family doc but now is finding that the
journals weren't really telling the
truth and we've got a problem it turns
out that how our medical knowledge is
generated changed radically in the last
15 or 20 years we've gone through a
phase before 1980 most clinical research
was financed by the National Institutes
of Health and other nonprofit sources
during the 80s the Reagan years we got
into the small-government era in an
economic downturn and the funding for
clinical research dried up from the
public sector the drug companies were
very happy to step in and provide the
funds to do the research even so most of
that research stayed within the
universities so by 1991 about 70% of
clinical research was being paid for by
the drug companies but the vast majority
of that was being done in universities
where there's still checks and balances
where the researchers still played a
major
roll and decide designing the research
where they had access to the data to
analyze it and they had control over
publication but during the 1990s that
changed very radically where 80% of that
research was being done in universities
in the beginning of the 90s by the time
we get to 2000 only 34 percent of that
research was being done in universities
it went to it got moved out of the
universities to for-profit research
companies and that's not inherently
unethical it made sense for the drug
companies to do that it was less
expensive they could do the research
more quickly they had less
administrative red tape they had to go
through the problem is that it gave the
pharmaceutical industry far more control
over the research because these
for-profit companies were dependent on
the drug companies for their next
contract so what happened is the
research started to be Madrid companies
started to play a far greater role in
the design of the research the analysis
of the research this one was hard for me
to believe but many of the authors of
our most important articles in our best
journals many of the authors are not
given access to all the data they're
only given access to data that the
research company pharmaceutical industry
allows them to see so the data is
parceled out and as we learned in the
antidepressant debacle the last few
months much meant much of the time that
research doesn't come out in the drug
companies favor it's actually not
published and then it doesn't become
part of the scientific evidence so with
the antidepressants in children and
adolescents issue that's been
percolating for the last year about a
year ago there were 15 studies that had
been done on the safety and
effectiveness of antidepressants in
children and adolescents but only six of
them had been published the six that
were published showed that the drugs
were effective and were safe on review
by the FDA and by the British drug
authorities it turns out only three of
those studies really stood up to
scrutiny that they reported the primary
endpoint that they said they were going
to report so three out of the 15 studies
really show that those drugs were safe
and effective
the other studies that were not
published showed the drugs were not
effective for depression and children
and adolescents and that they
significantly increase the risk of
suicidal behavior now what happened was
the drug companies did not publish those
studies and it looks to an outside
observer that the drug companies were
protecting their own interest at the
risk of exposing kids who were depressed
to taking a drug that was going to
increase significantly increase suicidal
behavior that strikes me is not okay to
complicate matters on that story the
epidemiologist in charge of that
investigation had a report prepared to
present at an FDA advisory committee
meeting in February of 2004 as the
meeting approached the epidemiologist
was told he was not welcomed at that
meeting where he was they they had FDA
scientists in charge of this he was not
welcome and his report was not welcomed
the higher-ups at the FDA said his
conclusions were premature that this was
a big decision and that it needed to go
more slowly even though the Brits had
already warned their Doc's that these
there might be harm in children and
adolescents the FDA gave this
information out to an independent team
at Columbia to review the independent
team came up with exactly the same
conclusions and in September the
Advisory Committee met again and found
decided that the original report was
accurate and that they're going to
change the labeling on these drugs the
point being that with the
antidepressants with Vioxx celebrex i
won't go into but we can talk about
later if people are interested Doc's who
are looking at the scientific evidence
which means the evidence that's
available are not looking at all of the
research evidence and weed Doc's who are
trying to practice good medicine for our
patients are getting a very biased view
of what the science is really showing us
this is a real problem in fact there was
an article in that was published in the
journal the American Medical Association
2003 that looked at only the
highest-quality research and found that
if you look at only the highest quality
research the research that's funded by
the drug industry the odds are five
times greater that that research funded
by the drug industry is going to find in
favor of their product than research
that's non-commercially funded so Doc's
who are reading these articles can't
sort through the article in JAMA
concluded that people who read these
articles need to be careful that the
conclusions that are drawn follow from
the data this is what says in general
the American Medical Association
well a Doc's don't have the time to do
these statistical calculations on their
own and B they don't have access to the
data oftentimes the authors the articles
don't even have access to the data this
is the situation we're in it's a tough
situation it's a bad situation now it
gets even more complicated because as
you're probably aware Doc's
clinical practice guidelines define the
standards of good care for doctors and
not just define the standards of good
care but the clinical practice
guidelines formulated by experts are
admissible in malpractice cases in court
so if Doc's don't follow those
guidelines they can get sued the
guidelines that were formulated by the
American College of Rheumatology in 2000
about treating osteoarthritis wear and
tear arthritis recommended that Doc's
prescribed acetaminophen or Tylenol
first and then next on the list was
celebrex and Vioxx well turned out that
all four of the doctors who wrote those
guidelines had financial ties with at
least one of the manufacturers of
celebrex and Vioxx and it turns out that
that's not an anomaly another article in
the journal American Medical Association
showed that amongst the experts who
formulate these guidelines that define
the standards of care that your doctors
must practice at risk of being sued or
being being called to the carpet for not
practicing high-quality medicine amongst
those experts 59 percent have financial
ties
with drug companies who have a drug
that's being decided upon in that
guideline process active financial
relationship so these are the experts
who are setting the standards that your
docs a believe and trust are good
standards and must practice in accord
with or risk malpractice suit which
brings me up to the latest cholesterol
guidelines I'm sure most of you are
aware that in July there was a revision
of the recommendations for the treatment
of cholesterol and the threshold for
prescribing a statin drug was lowered
for people who do not yet have heart
disease it's called primary prevention
people who do not yet have heart disease
but are at moderate or high risk for
developing heart disease the threshold
for starting a cholesterol-lowering
statin drug was lowered from a hundred
an LDL cholesterol of 130 down to a
hundred now 5/6 of adults have LDL
levels above 100 or above so that means
we're going to expand the number of
people taking cholesterol-lowering drugs
by a lot these recommendations were
published in circulation which is the
Journal of the American Heart
Association and no conflicts of interest
were declared but it turns out that
eight out of the nine experts who who
participated in writing those guidelines
have financial ties to the drug
companies one of those experts is a
full-time employee of the National
Institutes of Health and oversees the
division of MEK molecular biology which
oversees the guideline process these
guidelines that expert had the most
conflicts of interest relation financial
relationships with 10 drug companies now
this is a problem it's not just that
there's conflicts of interest that
weren't disclosed but the
recommendations themselves need to be
questioned because the recommendations
say that women who don't yet have heart
disease who are marched to high risks
should be treated with a statin drug if
their cholesterol is a hundred or their
LDL is 100 or above
but it may come as a surprise to you
that there is no evidence from
randomized clinical trials that statin
drugs help women who don't have heart
disease there is none so the millions of
women who are taking a statin drug who
don't have heart disease are taking it
on the basis of an extrapolation from
men but the studies themselves don't
show it in fact the one study that did
address primary prevention women that
was included in these new guidelines
it's called the ascot study there were
2,000 women they had high blood pressure
and at least three other risk factors
for heart disease half of the women took
were randomized to take lipitor and half
to take a placebo the half that were
randomized to take lipitor developed 10%
more heart attacks than the women who
took placebo not statistically
significant but it certainly calls into
question this idea that the studies
aren't big enough and don't go on long
enough and if the and the trends would
if we let it go longer the trends would
show that these drugs are affected same
for the elderly people over 65 the
recommendations are that we treat those
folks and much many more of those folks
are at moderate or high risk just
because of their age there's no
statistically significant evidence that
statins help those folks the important
thing is the subtitle of my book is the
broken promise of American medicine the
important point with cholesterol is that
about 80% of our risk of heart disease
doesn't have to do with our cholesterol
it has to do with how we live our lives
do we exercise eat a mediterranean-style
diet not smoke drink in moderation have
a healthy body weight women who do those
things have 17% as much heart disease as
the women who don't do those things the
problem with our medical care is because
most of the clinical research is being
funded by the drug companies and the
guidelines are being written by people
who have financial ties to drug
companies we Doc's get focused narrowly
on the cholesterol issue the study came
out in the Journal of the American
Medical Association just three or four
weeks ago
7300 women were followed in Chicago for
31 years so healthy women followed for
31 years kind of a Framingham Heart
Study like studied and looked at the
contribution of overall mortality of
smoking blood pressure diabetes
cholesterol race I think were the five
things the contribution of cholesterol
to overall mortality in these women zero
point zero zero zero point zero zero and
when we look at older folks if you just
look at four things with older folks
forget cholesterol blood pressure
everything if you just look at four
things do the exercise eat a
mediterranean-style diet not smoke and
drink in moderation people over 65 who
just do those four things reduce their
death rate by 60% and yet there's no
evidence that taking a statin for those
folks is going to reduce their death
rate by 60% the problem is that Doc's
spend about three or four times more
time and energy talking to their
patients about lowering their
cholesterol then about making the
changes in their life that would really
protect them from cardiovascular disease
and protect their health overall
so our medicine is off track it's about
the wrong thing that's the real message
that I want to convey 70 to 80% of our
health is in our own hands and yet our
health care system spends about 95% of
its money on the other 20 or 30% the
purpose of our medical knowledge the
very purpose of our medical knowledge
has been transformed from serving our
health to serving corporate bottom lines
and in fact this is the drug companies
job they're no more responsible for our
health than the fast-food industry is
responsible for the quality of our diet
so the problem is when the drug
companies are acting ethically and
sometimes they don't and we can talk
about that the problem is when the drug
companies are acting ethically we're in
a situation now where it says if they
were a professional football team and
they were allowed to referee the game
the drug companies can't
possibly referee their own game
capitalism can't function that way in
the same way that we expect a government
to enforce contracts nobody would say
that that's intrusive amount of
government to enforce contracts we've
got to expect our government to oversee
the quality of the medical knowledge
that's being produced and I think in
order to do that we need to number one
educate ourselves educate our doctors I
think we need to have congressional
hearings to look at the relationship
between the clinical data and the FDA
and the medical journals and the
marketing and the clinical guidelines I
think we need a federal body like the
Federal Reserve Board that looks at all
the clinical information that with with
that is as free of commercial influence
and political influence and some not
subject to getting the funds cut so that
the American people and American
physicians have a place to turn to for
unbiased complete accurate knowledge
we're going to need those things if our
Doc's are going to be able to practice
good medicine and if our patients are
going to be able to come to us with
information that's not supplied by the
drug companies but information that's
supplied by impartial sources so
intelligent people can get accurate
information and share that with their
doc we reestablishing this
doctor-patient relationship whose
primary purpose is not to fatten the
corporate bottom lines but whose primary
purpose is to improve the health of the
American people so in that note I'll
I'll finish and maybe we could take some
questions
can you speak a little bit to the effect
of the advertisement of pharmaceutical
drugs on on television and patients
walking in requesting these drugs and
how that has eroded the relationship yes
would you John would you please address
the issue of the blatant advertisement
of drugs on television it's interesting
that they seem to come at the NewsHour
when we're most stressed out and that's
when we get our ads for private call and
prevacid and and nexium and all that and
and few other things but how that
requests patients coming in and
requesting these drugs sort of erodes
away at the actual relationship with the
physician has with the patient
absolutely direct to consumer
advertising is a recent phenomenon it
started in 1985 but in 1991 the drug
companies were only spending 55 million
dollars last year it was up to 3.8
billion dollars the number of ads that
people see on TV increased 40 fold from
1994 to 1999 the problem that the drug
companies would argue that they're
providing a public service by educating
the problem is that to the extent that
it's education it's only education that
serves to sell their product it's not
education that serves to improve overall
health it doesn't talk about other
approaches it doesn't talk about the
lifestyle contribution to the disease
the real problem is these ads are
masterfully designed when you see the
documents from the advertisers they
understand that they're not working on a
cognitive level they're not their job is
not to communicate the facts the science
their job is to connect at an emotional
level so when we see Dorothy Hamill the
former Olympic champion skater lacing up
her skates and saying I'm so happy that
I can skate again
and she's taking Vioxx the implication
obviously is that she's getting better
relief than she did before and yet Vioxx
if anything is slightly less effective
the vigor study shows just slightly less
effective than their proxxon so the drug
company is creating this emotional
response and then what they're doing is
playing on people's autonomy creating
this false sense of autonomy so that if
you don't go to your doctor if you have
arthritis and and and you're having
troubles singing or dancing and singing
is not a problem but dancing or or
running or playing tennis that you're
really sort of a adult if you don't go
to your doctor and demand that and if
you don't get it you've lost the
confrontation well as a family doc that
was just so destructive because people
come each one is unique the data is we
talked about whoops we talked about the
five to one odds of commercially
sponsored research finding in favor of
the drug it turns out the drug is
actually less safe so patients are
coming
we've lost the whole meaning of a
doctor-patient encounter because now it
becomes a contest of wills about who
whether patient wins by getting the
Vioxx or the doctor wins by not giving
the Vioxx and the truth is everybody
loses except for the drug company
everybody loses nice study looked at how
doctors how confident doctors felt about
the treatment that they rendered when
they prescribed a drug that was asked
for versus a drug they suggested and it
turns out that doctors are four times
more likely to be ambivalent about their
prescription when the drug is requested
by the patient it makes sense because
what are the odds that are commercially
a commercial message is going to hit the
right drug now boxes is a good example
because in 2000 mark knew that they
didn't have a very good drug what was
their approach they put more money into
marketing Vox than it had ever been put
into marketing a drug before they spent
160 million dollars advertising Vioxx to
consumers in 2000 that was more than was
spent marketing Pepsi or Budweiser beer
can
sensing us that we would be able to have
fun in a way that we hadn't had fun
enjoy physical activity in a way that we
hadn't and the patients are coming in I
overlapped a little bit as a part-time
doctor when I was making the transition
from being a full-time doctor to a
full-time researcher I overlapped a
little bit and I understood the Vioxx
data people would come to me now I was
spending hours and hours and hours in
this primary data I knew as much about
this the truth about Vioxx as as anybody
knew people would come to me and say I
want five so well it's it's not that
it's not effective it's a little more
dangerous it's gonna cost ten or fifteen
times more than so my insurance pays us
I would say nonetheless it's not a good
drug for you there's a danger in it they
would say but my friends are getting it
from their doctors and my friends are
going to specialists and the specialists
are prescribing it and you're just a
family doc so you can't know about it
you can't know about it
well Barbara starfield is a wonderful
lady University distinguished professor
at Johns Hopkins who does research on
health care systems finds that when when
health care is based on primary care
medicine the outcomes are better for
less money when health care is based on
specialty care of Medicine the outcomes
are worse for more money it plays into
this whole it's a whole system there's
that you can't put your finger anywhere
but it's a system that works like a
symphony at every place of information
transfer to the public and to doctors
the commercial interests are insinuating
their influence as much as they can
you spent considerable amount of time
tracing the relationship the changing
relationship between the pharmaceutical
companies and the research group but you
seem to avoid talking about the
responsibility that the editors of the
New England Journal or Journal of JAMA
have on accepting or rejecting these
articles surely they know the funding
source and surely they can check the
denied relationship between the the
investigator and the funding source
absolutely it's a very good question if
we look at this celebrex case we let's
look at both locks and celebrate so if
we look at the celebrex case the article
was published there was a large an eight
thousand person study that looked at
celebrex just like the Vioxx study funds
sponsored by Pharmacia which has become
part of Pfizer now the conclusion of
that article in JAMA in September of
2000 was that celebrex when taken for
six months produces fewer GI problems
the truth is that it wasn't a six month
study it was a 12-month study and all 12
months had been done and analyzed at the
time that the six-month paper was
submitted to JAMA the editor of JAMA and
one of the two Doc's who wrote the
editorial in that dish in September 2000
when they found out that they had not
been allowed to see the other six months
had not been submitted nor was there any
evidence that there was another six
months of data when they found that out
they said to the Washington Post they
the guy who wrote the editorial said I'm
flabbergasted I'm furious I had no idea
there was another six months of data the
editor of JAMA said to the Washington
Post it's it's in August of 2001 you can
check it on LexisNexis said she thought
that we were operating on the basis of
trust but perhaps that was broken so the
now the the FDA had a pretty good
inkling of what was going on at the time
there is a real problem here that the
folks at JAMA didn't
know that there was more data that the
FDA did know when the folks at jam it
didn't so your question is right on
target the method of what we think of as
peer review doesn't work the peer
reviewers are just looking at the
article as it's submitted they don't get
access to the data that's not submitted
the pharmaceutical companies and and the
funding sources that you kind of expect
that to happen given the opportunity but
the editorial boards of these formerly I
guess prestigious journals are allowing
this to happen and when the editor is
caught to whom do they respond the
Washington Post you're exactly right I
mean in in the Wall Street absolutely in
the Wall Street Journal article that was
published this Monday about Vioxx the
editor the English remember the story
that the finding of doubling of
cardiovascular complications and that
there were 21% more significant
clinically significant serious
complications of people took Fox the
writers asked the executive editor of
the New England Journal how this could
have happened
basically they asked of him the same
question you're asking of me his
response was that and I'm paraphrasing
I'm not quoting but his response was the
editors went to great lengths to make
sure that they had the cardiovascular
data that's what look at the article in
the New England in The Wall Street
Journal the fact is that the article
says the New England Journal of Medicine
article says Merck sponsors the article
and it says we measured cardiovascular
complications and they'll be presented
in a later meta-analysis so for the
editor of the New England Journal to say
we went to great lengths to make sure we
had all the cardiovascular data it says
in black and white that they have that
Merck has the data and they're not
presenting it this is when I use the
analogy of the dentist drilling the
cavity but not getting to the bottom I
think that this is really the bottom
this is where the rubber hits the road
when we talk about medical knowledge
it's not research data you
can't ask Doc's to go to primary
research data and draw their own
conclusions you would have nobody could
practice medical knowledge means what
gets through into the most prestigious
medical journals and the docs have to be
able to trust that there's a huge
problem there and we're not yet getting
to it until we get to it this system is
going to go on there is no question
about it we're going to forget about
Vioxx and we're going to the next
struggle come along that the that all of
us Doc's believe the work better than
the drug it's replacing but we're not
going to fix it so the question really
is to whom are their journals
responsible and I think the answer must
be they've got to be responsible to the
American people they're defining what
our health how we're going to be treated
medically and they're defining how we're
going to spend our money so I think this
is a major problem and if we need to
address a lot of things in our health
care system I think that this is the
source of a lot of the trouble thank you
your book has been in the media now for
a while so I'm sure that the editors of
both New England Journal of Medicine in
JAMA a way of the opposition and I
personally want to compliment you on the
thoroughness of your research thank you
for this book also and for your
motivation for writing the book my
question is have you had any personal
feedback from the editors of either of
the journals no no in a word but I hope
to and I would love to participate in a
constructive dialogue because I don't
think it's black and white I think
they're shades of grey and I think most
of the people who are involved in this
business are trying to do the right
thing the system is broken
there's too much drug money in it
there's no question about that in my
mind that's black and white that we need
to take the commercial influence we need
to reduce the commercial influence in
our healthcare system but I think we
ought to be having a dial that dialogue
now last night on ABC News when they did
the article of the the the story about
Vioxx Richard Horton is the editor of
The Lancet it's a British Medical
Journal he is on the subject and he is
saying that the FDA is woefully
inadequate grossly grossly inadequate in
doing its job in protecting the safety
of the American people so there it's not
like nobody's on the issue and yet the
drug that the journals get a lot of
prestige when they published these big
these big articles drug company
sponsored articles and I was surprised
to learn that the pharmaceutical
industry can pay up to a million dollars
for reprints of these articles so this
is a very lucrative business to get the
important journal articles that flow
that the drug companies are going to
want reprints of and if the drug
companies want reprints of them you
better believe there's a commercial
advantage to having reprints out of them
so it's a it's a whole system and I
don't want to leave anybody with the
message that you can put your finger
anywhere in the system and that's the
problem and you can fix it it needs to
be fixed at multiple levels you talked
about marketing couple
and I was thinking about drug prices and
when prozac came out there was not a
huge market for antidepressants and they
they marketed the Prozac at about a
dollar 40 per capsule
when it hit the streets in 1989 and
within a few years it was at least 2 to
40 per capsule and I'm sure when a
higher after that drug companies claim
they need to have high prices to
stimulate research and yet my
understanding is most drug companies
really don't do research these days they
farmed that out to small biotech
companies they do mainly marketing and
I'm wondering I'm to my mind you know
half when a prozac ended up being about
two billion US sales per year I wonder
if you could comment on just what
happens with the price creep when
there's no obvious reason why it should
go up since the research was already
done the articles were written and yet
they're just plain doubling the price
apparently because that's what the
market could bear that's exactly right
and that's the answer that's what the
market could bear the United States is
the only only industrialized country
that lets drug prices rise to what the
market will bear so it's a simple
business school issue of how high should
you raise the unit cost before it starts
compromising your sales enough so that
your profits go down we're the only
country that that prices are drugs like
that every other country has a mechanism
of pricing so that the drugs are that
you can't price a drug higher it's
called reference pricing you can't price
a drug higher than the lowest price drug
in its class that's equally effective is
the sort of classic model of reference
pricing but you raise a very important
issue because the United States is
different our health care system is
different than other countries health
care system you know there's a reason
why we're spending twice as much in
getting poor results with the only
industrialized country that doesn't have
universal health care coverage and we're
the only industrialized country that
allows drugs to be priced so that
it's as high as the market will bear the
American people don't support that
a recent survey showed that 85% of
Americans think that drug companies
should not be allowed to charge what the
market will bear and the argument that
the drug companies need to charge this -
this much money to keep their R&D
pipeline going Falls a little bit
becomes a little bit dubious when we
realize that net of all research and
development costs the drug companies
profit margin on sales is 18% but the
average fortune 500 companies profit
margin is 4 or 5% this is a little hard
to make the argument that they need to
charge those prices when they're making
three four sometimes five times as much
profit as the other fortune 500
companies so what we have is a
market-based healthcare system and the
American people that's not the values of
the American people Americans eight
seventy nine percent of Americans think
there should be universal health care
and are willing to give up pay more
taxes to have universal health care and
yet we're not moving in that direction
85 percent think that drugs shouldn't be
allowed to be priced at what the market
will bear
so I think in this political season I
think we ought to look at values what
the real values are here what what the
shared values of Americans are there
there's a there's a social contract
there's a basic decency amongst
Americans where eighty percent of
Americans say all Americans should have
health care 76 percent say health care
is a right not a privilege and yet we're
not allowed to get there so when I I
think as we move forward now and values
have been defined as a major issue in
our country I think we got to look at
the real values this is a real value
where people care about each other and
yet we're not allowed to get there it's
not a scientific problem it's a
political problem and I think as long as
values now have been injected in our
political debate it's our job to make
sure they're that we look at the real
values that make a difference in
people's lives
I think this was a very realistic
analysis you gave but what I just wanted
to kind of mention is and for your
thought of all our thought is that
threatened things happen in certain
markets in certain cultures and the
American in general was not born in this
country obviously is a very impatient
person and he wants to have immediate
results and the result he would like is
a pill quick fix and that's a big
problem because and I'm also helped to
be a physician that to tell a patient
who was overweight who was smoking to
stops us is very I mean he may has many
times difficulties to accepts us that
that's his duty that's what he should be
doing and we know that actually most of
our health care problems right now are
self induced I mean you alluded to this
and so if a person gains weight and
smokes the burden for the health care
system ten years down the line is
perhaps to in effect
thousand dollars a day or to thousands
at all a day of pills he has to take to
combat all these different consequences
so that's a major major problem and so
it's it's a culture which allows this to
happen it doesn't happen in every
culture right right and I I agree with
everything you've said and in our
impatient market-based culture what
we've allowed to happen is we've allowed
this commercialization of our medical
knowledge so that the drug companies can
exploit exactly what you're talking
about by controlling the information
that we have and promising us that we
will be able to fix these things I mean
the best example is the I forget which
statin it's advertising but
on one side of the TV screen is the
statin on the other is a big fat steak
suggesting that you can have both just
eat you can eat your steak and just take
your statin and it's okay but as most of
us know that's not okay because the diet
that we eat is a health risk independent
of what the cholesterol level is so if
it worked it would be one thing and we
would say well you know maybe the word
this is our culture and this is how we
the antidote to it but it doesn't even
work and that's the problem so it's
really exploitation plus I think that we
physicians have a responsibility to do
exactly what you're saying if the
patient is still smoking and still
overweight and I think as a physician
it's my responsibility to work with them
to help them figure out what the
impediments to getting their lives in
order I'm an archivist studying the
history of American printed advertising
thank you
and I'm curious about your cover design
was it yours
the publishers how did it come to being
and I may or may not have a comment
depending upon your answer well it's a
group effort actually the the publisher
came up with the first draft
Charlotte Kahn is my significant other
and made some very important
modifications in the type and in the
coloring I think I had a contribution or
two but it was a team effort but the
publisher played the biggest role and
the cover was designed after 9/11 yes
yes okay my point would be that
manipulation is a tricky thing and it's
necessary in marketing and survival a
lot in business and sometimes it's
innocent and sometimes it's not you
suggested the example of Sonia Henning
in a TV ad Dorothy Hale or Dorothy
Hamill sorry that that was actually
creating an emotional response
the iconographic effect of your cover
means something entirely different today
than it would have pre 9/11 and I've
actually been collecting imagery of 9/11
advertising affected by 9/11 so you know
I just wonder where are your thinking
was on that because the general public
is going to look at your cover and think
subliminally subconsciously or not
they're gonna connect it to what's going
on in the whole world with 9/11
interesting point I mean there was
clearly no intention of doing that
the intention was what our physician
friend just spoke about which is the
market orientation that has that now
permeates our medical culture and is
really a part of American culture deeply
ingrained in American culture and what
I've tried to do in this book is through
my expertise as a physician and
researcher to explain the consequences
of this over alliance of on the market
in the one little niche of America that
I know about which is our health care so
to the extent that it evokes or exploits
any image of a tragedy of 9/11 that is
certainly not what I had in mind nor if
anybody had said that was the purpose
the cover I would have said then forget
it go to something else that's not the
image the image is that I hope to evoke
is the over Alliance on market on
markets to solve social problems and I
think that's the key theme that I want
to get across in the field of medicine
just a little rejoined her I interrupt
you for a minute they're gonna stop the
tape you can continue the discussion and
there are refreshments in the back of
somebody's restless and let's just stand
up thank you well thank you very much
John Abramson teaches primary care at
Harvard Medical School and has worked as
a family doctor in Appalachia and
Hamilton Massachusetts overdosed America
the broken promise of American medicine
is published by HarperCollins on the web
at HarperCollins com